народний депутат України автор
резонансних журналістських розслідувань
був головою української делегації в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи і
віце-президентом парламентської асамблеї
Ради Європи голова Хмельницької
територіальної організації партії
європейська
Солідарність Дякую друзі Слава Україні
Слава я Вітаю Сьогодні дуже велике свято
сьогодні Михайлове чудо і це церковне
свято завжди для українців є приво
зібратися родиною і поговорити про свої
справи А ще кажуть що в цей день яко би
бажання молитовне ми не згадали воно
збудеться і я знаю наше бажання спільне
це перемога на виборах 25 жовтня
правда Я впевнений що з такою командою
яку ми зібрали на Хмельниччині Ми
переможемо Тому що тут досвід і новизна
тут фаховість і професійність і тут
найголовніше є розум чого бракувало
Останній рік в українській владі у нас в
команді підприємці аграрії освітяни
медики люди з бездоганною репутацією і
ті які своїми вчинками і справами довели
своє право представляти Хмельницьку
громаду
в інтересах саме громади кожного
хмельничанина І ми будемо це робити
разом І тому я сьогодні з особливою
приємністю і для мене є особлива честь
представити зараз людину яка сьогодні
щойно прибула до нас на партійну
конференцію пятого президента України
людину яка почала рух України в Європу
голову партії європейська Солідарність
Петра
порошенкалі нам роїни на сходи Не сміє
брат на
братакиі Володя Дуже дякую тобі за таке
урочисте
представлення дорогі друзі Я дуже скучив
по
Хмельницькому Я дуже радий вас всіх
бачити і вчора Володя дуже
наполегливо вимагав щоб наша зустріч
відбулася саме сьогодні
Зустріч з найкращими представниками які
від європейської
солідарності від
єдиної проукраїнської демократичної
опозиційної сили парламентської в
Україні яки зараз має зберегти
розбудувати і розвинути Україну яка має
забезпечити
збереження нашого
руху до
Європи до Європейського Союзу до
членства до членства в
НАТО чому Це зараз так важливо і чому
цей рух знаходиться в
небезпеці Вчора я дуже уважно продивився
показники бюджету
який був запропонований цією зеленою
некомпетентною
владою кажуть що бюджет - це є
економічна Конституція Я з цим не
погоджуюсь конституція у нас є одна і в
Конституції чітко зазначено що
метою курсу України є членство в
Євросоюзі і НАТО але бюджет бюджет це є
як
сповідь
що прагне які є пріоритети у
влади що вони вважають за необхідне
підтримати і
розвинути А що вони дуже дуже не
люблять от Я Хочу
наголосити пріоритетом для мене завжди
була оборона і безпека
держави перед прийняттям бюджету
відбувалося засідання під моїм керівни
Ради нацбезпеки і оборони і ми
забезпечували поступове і
щорічне зростання видатків на оборону
поступове і
щорічне зростання грошового забезпечення
наших воїнів поступове і
щорічне виплати військовим які воюють в
зоні операції об'єднаних
сил другий
пріоритет під час війни під час відсічі
агресії це є пріоритет місцевого
самоврядування пріоритет
громад децентралізації і фінансового
наповнення можливостей місцевого
самоврядування припинена Практика коли з
областей з торбами їздять до Кабміну і
до Мінфіну для того щоби випросити гроші
на розвиток
громади
навпаки фінансова база місцевих рад
бюджети розвитку були
збільшені в 5 7 10 а по окремим
територіальним громадам 18 і 20
разів Отже принципова позиція - це
реалізація нашого з вами курсу на
децентралізацію і створення фінансової
основи місцевого самоврядування що ми
бачимо зараз які є пріоритети в діючої
Влади армія
уявить собі під час війни вони
скоротили видатки на збройні сили
України воювати Вони не збираються Вони
збираються
капітулірувати Це є символ розуміння
державності з
боку популістської некомпетентної
зеленої
команди що ще вони скоротили
Міністерство ветеранів
не потрібно шанувати
ветеранів в них інши
пріоритет що ще вони скоротили
субсидії для того щоб
виплачувати компенсації
малозабезпеченими це їх
пріоритет А де ж вони
додали перше що треба було додати це
гроші адвокату Януковича
бабіко який стоїть на чолі дбр
цей
пріоритет
бабікови з
дбр які кидають за грати
патріотів бабікові з дбр які порушили
кримінальні
справи в тому числі До речі і проти двох
фантастичних
жінок Марусі звіробій і Софії федини
депутата нашої фракції європейської
солідарності за що за пост в Фейсбуці що
ж вони зробили цим постом вони дуже
налякали
Зеленського і він подав заяву як
Потерпілий від цих двох жінок
це їх
бачення Я не кажу кинули заграти
ріфмайстера доброго друга
Володі і одного з засновников
Спецназу я не буду розкривати його роль
в створенні сил спеціальних операцій Але
можу сказати що
гін спецпризначенців написано саме ним
вони створюють загрозу для діючої
влади і
їм дбру дано доручення розправлятися
збільшено на 40% видатки на офіс
Генерального прокурора
збільшені значно видатки на офіс
[музика]
президента і державне управління
справами які
забезпечує державні
дачі бо він вивести вивіз туди і сів
там Хочу наголосити що за час моєї
каденції В адміністрації президента
зарплати були на 30% нижче ніж в кабміні
це теж несправедливо але чітко
демонструє
пріоритет Я ніколи в житті не
користувався для життя державними
дачами так само як і державними
кортежами вони на кортеж висунули
стільки грошей що в усьому світі
велосипедів не
хвати так вони бачать майбутнє нашої
держави дефіцит бюджету складає
7% вони витрачають незароблене
збільшуючи за останній місяць державний
бок на 2,5 млрд доларів за
місяць сподіваючись що ми спокійно за
цим будемо
спостерігати вчора оприлюднені цифри
економічного падіння це вже
пікет
штопа
11,4% падіння економіки за другий
квартал і це при тому що наша
команда 15 кварталів
поспіль майже 4отири роки поспіль в
умовах війни забезпечували економічне
зростання Вони кажуть Та ні це
просто вдача була в Порошенка
Що Само собою так
відбувалося ви Вибачте будь ласка але
вдача це запуск механізма proзоро з
прозорими державними тендерними
закупівлями яке ніколи не було в Україні
і ми це
зробили вдача
це
150го до 64го місця найбільший прогрес в
рейтингу doн бзнес щодоведення умов
бізнесу в
Україні вдача - це про рив наш на ринки
Європейського Союзу і щотижневі
переговори мої особисто з керівництвом
країн і з лідерами
Євросоюзу вдача - це децентралізація
вдача - це конкурс на посади в Державній
Службі вдача - це інклюзивна освіта
вдача - це нова українська школа вдача -
це нова система харчування для
військовослужбовців вдача вдача вдача ні
країні потрібна компетентна патріотична
і українська
влада якою Зараз ми
позбавлені позбавлені тому що країна
стала жертвою популізму людей обдурили
ще раз наголошую люди не винні бо
масована Атака з усіх без виключення
засобів масової інформації і тих які
належать п'ятій колоні Кремля і тих які
належать олігархам які вкрали з
державного банку зараз уже А тоді з
банківської
системи майже 7 млрдів доларів і Як
тільки ми оголосили їм
війну вони пішли війною на
нас і тому дорогі друзі Хочу
наголосити місцеві вибори
це не тільки і не стільки про
каналізацію хоча це
важливо місцеві вибори - це не тільки і
не стільки про ліфти чи про ремонт доріг
чи про освітлення чи про ремонт школи чи
дитячого садочку чи лікарні що важливо
ми це запустили за 5пть
років місцеві вибори
це про те як зберегти
країну і як ми з вами єдина команда в
об'єднаній громаді
в міськраді в облраді і наша фракція в
Верховній Раді України єдина яка
забезпечує захист українських інтересів
Бо коли ми з вами проводили
парламентську кампанію що ми казали
європейська Солідарність це наш
парламентський
Спецназ в парламенті для того щоби дати
по рукам тим хто буде руйнувати
Україну Уявіть собі що б було якби не
європейська Солідарність яка стала на
захист української
мови тричі вони виносили законопроект
щоби скасувати статус української мови
чому Бо закон який ми прийняли заважає
їм говорити
російською
Вибачте говоріть якою хочете
мовою але Не чіпайте
дітей кожен
українець обов'язково має знати
українську мову і Я не заперечую щоб
потім Он говорил на
русском малку разбирал
побелгарски
очевищеши Роу
[музика]
попольским
прошу європейською Україну а не за
шкірку ви назад втягнете нас в
радянський союз і в Російську імперію Ми
українці вам цього не
дозволимо і в цьому полягає що ми
зацементували нашу
Україну а ще ще перед нами стоїть
[музика]
загрози епідемії
коронавірусу вчора вони договорилися
Зеленський договорився до того що в
коронавірусі винні три
сили перше Це очевидно це
Порошенко бо він як там сказав
Монарх друге
це голови місцевого
самоврядування і третє
вибори Три речі які їм заважають жити
Уявіть собі і це говорять той і ті хто в
лютому місяці продали всі маски з
України за безнь залишивши 42мільйонну
націю без засобів
захисту
Вибачте це говорять Ті хто в березні
місяці заліз в кишені місцевого
самоврядування хотів залізти на 200 млрд
і коли ми дали по руках
залишилось 66 млрд коронавірусний фонд
звідки вони їх забрали у місцевого
самоврядування у культури в українського
культурного фонду в бібліотек в театрі в
українське кіно в українські книги
Подивіться що вони наробили і куди ж
вони спрямували ці
гроші я запропонував законопроект разом
з нашою фракцією проте застрахуйте
медиків так як ми застрахували
воїнів якщо лікар лікар коли йде до
хворого Він має відчувати що за ним
стоїть
держава дайте йому ліки дайте йому
засоби захисту і дайте йому
страхування ми скликали позачергову
сесію Вони сказали що вони будуть
страхувати тільки тиіх хто
помре
які межі цинізму має
бути і пообіцяли переголосувати і більше
нічого не робили ми сказали з
коронавірусного Фонду тим хто працює з
коронавірусними хворими дайте 300%
заробітної
плати так як ми це робили воїнам які
воюють в зоні АТО бо це
фронт вони обдурили знаєте чому бо вони
ті хто перебуває в контакті з
коронавірусними хворими почали
похвилинну тарифікацію от Скільки хвилин
ти пробув стільки вони будуть
виплачувати грошей це
знущання І після того всього що було
зроблено коли вони коли в країні було
три хворих ні три сотні ні 3 000 ні 300
000 а три вони оголосили
карантин і поклали економіку
не просто як абстрактне поняття вони
заборонили
працювати дрібному
підприємцю який працює в рукарні який
працює в кафешкі який працює в сфері
туристичного бізнесу який працює в сфері
послуг чи розваг
закрили а самі депутати від слуг народа
разом з своєю зеленою
керівництвом відпочивали в ресторанах
велюр
бо це інша
Каста так вони бачать зелену
Україну І от ми з вами
це Велика місія
історична ми з вами
маємо це зупинити
[музика]
чому Тому що не так небезпечен
коронавірус як звірус
зелений
вірус який руйнує економіку який руйнує
державність який нападає на
церкву який руйнує армію який руйнує всі
реформи які ми свого часу
започаткували і на сьогоднішній
день Останнє що вони намагалися
зруйнувати - це
безвіз
на цьому тижні вони винесли проект
постанови
якою повністю зруйнувати антикорупційну
інфраструктуру яка спільно з нашими
західними партнерами коли я створював
всесвітню коаліцію на підтримку України
підтримку в протидії російськії агресії
і підтримку в протидії в проведенні
реформ вони
звільнили і ректора набу і
спеціалізованого антикорупційного
прокурора і Зараз дали можливість оцим
п'ятій колоні Росії Опа зж
і
коломойському сформувати ручну комісію
для призначення назначенця Зеленського
який буде стовідсотково його
людиною яка була реакція
світу ми вам більше не
віримо реакція євро
парламент будете йти цим шляхом
призупинимо
безвіз реакція світового банку прийняте
рішення по 350
млн ми призупиняємо гроші вам не дамо ви
їх
крадете реакція єврокомісії прийняте
рішення по 600 млн євро макрофінансової
допомоги ми вам не
даємо Ви маєте
продемонструвати незалежність
корупційної
інфраструктури і моя позиція да Яка була
реакція нашої
влади чули це все Порошенко він нас
лякає Порошенко командує єврокомісію
європарламентом світовим банком
міжнародним валютним фондом це
дилетантство
це як я колись сказав
підлітки в нетверезому стані вирішили
політати на суперскладному літаку
Дорвалися до
штурвала Але ми з вами не маємо бути
простими пасажирами бо країна країна
знаходиться в небезпеці і як це
зупинити ще раз наголошую головне
досягнення нашої команди за п років Це
не ті реформи що я перелічив головне
досягнення - це те що ми перша команда
яка забезпечила реальне сування країни в
Європейський союз і в НАТО ми з вами
маємо це
продовжити друга
позиція Звичайно що на місцевих виборах
дехто хоче проголосувати за міцних
господарників друзі мої
міцни господарники мають працювати в
комунальних
підприємствах а лідером громади має бути
політик який буде мати представництво в
парламенті і який забезпечить захист
інтересів держави вірній йому громаді де
його обрали своїм лідером це є то
завдання які нам обов'язково треба буде
реалізувати
І тепер тепер я хочу сказати Я пишаюся
нашою командою Хмельницькій області ви
великі
молодці я точно довіряю вам і нам треба
буде зробити все щоби вам і нам повірили
люди я точно переконаний в тому щоби
ніякі місцеві проекти запущені
олігархами не дали Як 15 місяців тому
обдурити людей
ефективність дій європейської
Солідарності
в за останні 15 місяців в
опозиції ми продемонстрували мені не
соромно за жодного народного депутата
члена нашої фракції за жодне голосування
і за жодні ефективні дії які ми зробили
в парламенті і за його межами да це
нелегко вчора під генеральною
прокуратурою Олексій ганчаренко оголосив
що вони вийшли на Книгу рекордів
Гіннеса порушивши проти мене 58
кримінальних
справ думаючи що нас залікають
О це ще вони нас не
знають дорогі друзі Ми потужна сильна
європейська команда Ми команда яка
створила потужний базис української
державності і армію і мову захистили і
віру отримавши томос і економіку
забезпечили її поступовий рух вперед Я
дуже розраховую на вас І я дуже
прошу дорогі
хмельничани
підтримайте вашу і нашу європейську
Солідарність Дякую Вам слава Хмельницьку
Слава Хмельниччині і слава Україні слава
дорогі друзі а зараз запрошуємо на сцену
команду Хмельницької
області
Руслан скримський Галина Карнасевич
Олександр співак Валентин Соколюк Аліна
Коваль Євген Золотухін Світлана
баранськава петросюк Сергій шлегель Ніла
Островська Василь копильник друзі
[музика]
гучніше кандидати на голів отг
Ізяславська міська об'єднана
територіальна громада шлегель Сергій
Вадимович депутат першого скликання і
зяславської міської ради який у 1991
році підняв прапор незалежності України
над радою ще доброго оголошення
Незалежності
Красилівська міська об'єднана
територіальна громада Островська Ніла
Василівна яка успішно очолює
красилівську міську отг з кінця 2017
року Працюючи на посаді голови
красилівської РДА очолила
децентралізаційні процеси в районі
приділяла увагу розвитку як міста так і
села успіхи громади неодноразово
відзначали на міжнародних конференціях у
Канаді та Бель
кандидати депутати до міської ради
Сергій Золотухін діючий депутат
Хмельницької міської ради майже 20 років
займається бізнесом у сфері оптових
поставок продуктів харчування останній
рік активно включився у процес галузі
охорони
здоров'я Світлана баранська друзі вчніше
ваші
опски вперше обирається до складу
депутатів Хмельницької міської ради
більше 15 років займаєтьсяізне у сфері
нерухомості та транспорту останні пть
років активно включилася у вивчення
сфери торгівлі та підтримки малого та
середнього бізнесу у майбутній каденції
планує зосередитись саме На цьому
напрямку Івана петрасюк очолює молодіжне
крило європейської солідарності
громадська діячка протягом декількох
років сприяє розвитку молодіжної
політики та просвітницької діяльності в
місті
Хмельницькому
молодь прагне жити як в
Європі Перепрошую Ми прагнемо жити в
місті в Європейському місті і для цього
я буду залучати молодь Хмельницького до
розбудови в місті комфортних умов та
європейських стандартів кожен із нас
повинен долучатись до роботи у своєму
місті для того щоб зробити місто
європейським Ми повинні будувати Європу
тут а не за кордоном я зроблю усе щоб
діти та молодь Хмельниччини пишалися
Україною та нашою рідною хмельниччиною а
також вірю у те що команда європейської
солідарності може побудувати Європу тут
адже вона вже розпочала цю
роботу Василь кобильник кандидат у
депутати міської ради
кам'янця-подільського очолює список
проректор кам'янець-подільського
національ університету імені Івана
Огієнка голова фракції європейська
Солідарність у кам'янець-подільській
міській раді Доброго дня шановні друзі
думаю що ми усі погоджуємося із тим що
освіідчені люди є основою всіх країн
Євросоюзу адже освідчена і думаюча
людина ніколи не піддасться на
маніпуляції саме тому виступаю за
всебічну підтримку місцевою владою
розвитку якісної освіти буду домагатися
які
і належного фінансування вишів шкіл І
саме головне підтримки сучасних
європейських освітніх програм Влада має
повернутися обличчям до освітян а
освітяни мають відчути що їх професія
престижна думаю що знання і здоровий
глуст обов'язково переможуть Слава
Україні кандидати в депутати до обласної
ради Руслан скримський кандидат в
депутати у Хмельницьку обласну Раду від
від першого округу полонської громади
голова Полонського фермерського
господарства Колос учасник багатьох
фермерських
асоціацій своє комфортне життя Європа
будувала десятиріччями розпочала з того
що громади отримали кошти свої які могли
витрачати а не випрошувати інших також
хочу подякувати європейській
солідарності яка дійсно протягом цих пть
років зробила реформу
децентралізації які об'єднані
територіальні громади отримали кошти і
самостійно з ними
розпоряджалися також протягом пти років
продовжу цю реформу
децентралізації Слава Хмельниччині Слава
Україні Галина Карнасевич Директор
медичного центру МТК та мережі сучасних
аптек вітчизняного фармацевтичного
виробництва Юрія ферм голова Городоцької
районної організації європейської
солідарності Європейські країни медицину
роблять якісною особливо в такий
непростий час як тепер епідемія
коронавірусу показала неспроможність
української медицини до боротьби з
викликами які стали перед
нею гроші які з
коронавірусного фонду на жаль
розбазарили
здоров'я ним повинні керуватись ці а не
аматори і це не жарти з цим не жартують
тому я вважаю що
ми
запроваджуватимемо передові європейські
стандарти в боротьбі з
епідемією Олександр співак відомий
благодійник та меценат депутат
Хмельницької обласної ради генеральний
директор агропромислової групи компанії
а Group року за версією
загальнонаціональної програми людина
року
2016 українське суспільство потребує
потужних громад громад які розвивають
економіку які розвивають виробництво
які
розвивають аграрний сектор в громадах
дорогі друзі Я йду в органи місцевого
самоврядування для того щоб захистити
інтереси наших громад знаю точно що не
тільки вмію вирощувати хліб і
наповнювати бюджет Ми створюємо робочі
місця і думаємо про добробут наших людей
закликаю бути солідарними заради
європейської майбутнього нашої
держави Валентин
Соколюк керівник секретаріату
Хмельницької територіальної організації
європейської солідарності з 2014 року
член правління всеукраїнської
громадської організації стопкорупція
фаховий юрист європейська Солідарність
завжди буде підтримувати місцеві громади
і не дозволить знищувати їхні права та
повноваження здобуті завдяки реформі
децентралізації вважаю неприпустимим
нав'язування формування громад та
укрупнення районів незважаючи на думку
людей громади Хмельниччини мають бути
почути тому що європейські принципи - це
чути
людей
Аліна Коваль депутат волочиської міської
ради експерт з питань місцевого
самоврядування людина яка у перший же
тиждень чинності Закону України Про
добровільне утворення громад в Україні
ініціювала об'єднання громад у
волочиському районі стала волонтером
реформи децентралізації у 2015 році
кавалер ордену Княгині Ольги третьго
ступеню за підтримку громад
Хмельниччини з перших днів реформи ції я
займаюся її втіленням на Хмельниччині
консультую об'єднані територіальні
громади допомагаю їм зрозуміти які
великі можливості вони отримали завдяки
реформі від європейської
солідарності Я знаю чого прагнуть люди
як досягнути результату бо вже зробила
Це не на словах А на ділі мої прагнення
- це розвинені успішні українські міста
і
і я справді мрію побудувати Європу тут у
рідному
краї Володимир арв народний депутат
України автор резонансних журналістських
розслідувань бу був головою українською
делегацією парламентській асамблеї Ради
Європи і віце-президентом пар голова
Хмельницької територіальної організації
партії європейська
Солідарність кожен із нас хоче жити як в
Європі але багато хто ставить себе собі
питання а чи можливо це сумнівається в
цьому Та я хочу вам сказати
одне Європейські країни країни які
сьогодні є членами Євросоюзу ще не так
давно були такими самими як ми просто
вони повірили в себе і їм вдалося
змінити своє життя я не один раз був у
країнах Євросоюзу Я працював
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи і я
бачив як там живуть громади і Я
впевнений ми зможемо теж треба тільки
забути про солодкі обіцянки популістів а
нарешті дати громадам можливості і права
децентралізація яку розпочала команда
європейської
солідарності робила саме це будувала
європейські громади і тому Я впевнений
що ми збудуємо Європу
разом Слава
Україні